And now 99% invisible presents our new limited series, according to need. Here's your host, Katie Mingle. I live in the North part of Oakland near the border of Berkeley and Emeryville. Like other gentrifying places, this one was recently given a cutesy name by real estate agents hoping to attract new people to the area. No B for North Oakland, Berkeley, Emeryville. I'm not sure the name is stuck, but the new people certainly have. They've moved into the 1920s bungalows and craftsmen's, painting and landscaping, and refurbishing the neighborhood.
现在由 99% Invisible 推出我们的全新系列短片《按需分配》。我是主持人凯蒂·明格尔。我住在奥克兰北部，靠近伯克利和埃默里维尔的边界。像其他正在经历中产阶层化的地区一样，这个地方最近也被房地产经纪人们起了一个可爱的名字，希望能吸引新居民来到这里。北奥克兰、伯克利、埃默里维尔的首字母缩写就是 NOB。我不确定这个名字有没有叫开，但新居民确实留下来了。他们搬进了 20年代的平房和手工艺风格住宅，粉刷房屋、美化庭院，让这个社区焕然一新。
My girlfriend and I moved to this neighborhood last year, and we were thrilled to find our apartment, because it was two bedrooms with a nice big kitchen and a washer and dryer in the unit my first ever. All this and the rent was still under $3,000 a month, which for the area was actually extremely reasonable. I know, insane. But true. As we settled into the new place and started meeting neighbors, it didn't take long before we realized that some of them were homeless.
我和女友去年搬到了这个社区，我们很高兴能找到这套公寓，因为它有两个卧室，有一个漂亮的大厨房，而且屋里还有洗衣机和烘干机——这可是我头一次用上。这一切加上房租居然还不到每月 3000 美元，在该地区可以说是相当划算了。我知道，这太疯狂了。但这是真的。当我们在这个新地方安顿下来并开始结识邻居时，没过多久我们就发现他们中有些人是无家可归者。
There was a guy sleeping in an old Lexus right in front of our house and another guy who seemed to be living in the cabin of a boat parked on the side of the road just across the street from us. I was already working on this series about homelessness. So of course I went to go say hi to the boat guy. Knock knock. Yay. Yay.
有一个家伙睡在我们房子正前方的一辆旧雷克萨斯里，还有另一个家伙似乎住在马路对面路边停着的一艘船的船舱里。我当时已经在做这个关于无家可归者的系列报道了。所以，我当然得去跟那个住船上的家伙打个招呼。敲敲门。耶。耶。
Yay. Yay. Hi. Hey, how's it going? I'm your neighbor. Oh, how you doing? Good, how are you? I just took a bath soon.
耶。耶。嗨。嘿，最近怎么样？我是你的邻居。哦，你好吗？很好，你呢？我刚洗了个澡。
Right now I'm trying to get to work. I'm squinting up at my boat dwelling neighbor. His name is Michael. The vessel he lives on is a 15-foot speedboat with little sleeping cabin, and is named Graba Dupa, or something like that. Graba Dupa. Graba Dupa is a... Yeah.
我现在正赶去上班。我眯起眼睛抬头看着我这位住在船上的邻居。他叫迈克尔。他住的那艘船是一艘 15 英尺长的快艇，带有一个小小的睡眠船舱，名字叫 Graba Dupa 还是什么的。Graba Dupa。Graba Dupa 是个……对。
Quick but important interjection here, I found out later that Graba Dupa means fat ass and Polish. Did you... Who named it that? Grubba dupa coming through. Michael is wearing jeans and an orange florist invests and holding a hard hat. I find out later he's an electrician on a construction crew for a new high rise in San Francisco. Hi, so I live right over there and I'm also a journalist and I've been doing a bunch of reporting on people who are living like RVs and cars and I haven't talked to anyone that's living in a boat.
这里插播一个简短但重要的内容，我后来发现 Graba Dupa 在波兰语里是“大屁股”的意思。你……谁给它起这个名字的？Gruba Dupa 路过啦。迈克尔穿着牛仔裤、一件橙色的园艺背心，手里拿着一顶安全帽。我后来发现他是旧金山一处新建高层建筑施工队的电工。嗨，我刚好住在正那边，我也是个记者，我一直在做关于住在房车和汽车里的人的系列报道，但我还没采访过住在船上的人。
It's very fascinating. What I most want to know about Michael is where he's from, like where he lived before he was homeless. There's this persistent myth about homelessness, maybe especially persistent in California, that the homeless people here aren't really from here. Some people suggest that maybe folks came here from other areas to take advantage of better social services or better weather. But the data doesn't support this.
这太迷人了。我最想了解迈克尔的是他是哪里人，比如他在无家可归之前住在哪里。关于无家可归现象，有一种根深蒂固的迷思，在加州可能尤为顽固，那就是这里的无家可归者其实并非本地人。有些人暗示，也许人们从其他地区来到这里是为了利用更好的社会福利或更好的天气。但数据并不支持这种说法。
The last big survey done in Oakland found 78% of homeless respondents in the city of Oakland reported living in this county, Alameda County, at the time they became homeless. And most of the rest of the respondents just came from some other county in California. I suspect Michael is from Oakland, maybe even from this neighborhood. My mother knew you were some peace mom. We used to stay right there. Wait, where?
奥克兰进行的最后一次大型调查发现，该市 78% 的无家可归受访者表示，在他们无家可归时，他们就住在本县——阿拉米达县。其余的大多数受访者也只是来自加利福尼亚州的其他县。我怀疑迈克尔是奥克兰人，甚至可能就是这个社区的人。我母亲认识你，你是派斯妈妈。我们以前就住在那里。等等，哪里的？
You were in that house right there? I'm in the like beige all one Yeah, that's all one? Yeah, where do you used to stay there? You used to stay where I live? Yes, I'm me and my mother and my younger brother In case you didn't catch that with the traffic noise Michael is not only from this neighborhood
你以前就在那栋房子里？我是指那个米色的、整栋的。对，整栋都是吗？对，你以前在哪儿住过？你以前住在我现在住的地方吗？对，我和我母亲还有我弟弟。如果你刚才没听清背景里的交通噪音的话，迈克尔不仅是这个社区的人，
He used to live in my house. He tells me later he hasn't lived in that house for many years since the 1990s, and then he moved right next door, lived there for a bunch of years, and then he left the neighborhood for a while, struggled with addiction, got clean, and finally he ended up back here on the blocky most considers home and Murray still has friends from the old days. A lot of us me and Toefree wanted sleeps in the Lexus. Yeah. His dad used to stay in one two three four by five houses down they had a trucking company called Tofe Trucking. Nice trucks. Oh my God.
他还曾经住在我现在这栋房子里。他后来告诉我，他已经很多年没住在那栋房子里了，从 20 世纪 90 年代起就没有了，然后他搬到了隔壁，在那里住了好几年，接着他离开这个社区一段时间，与毒瘾作斗争，最终戒毒成功，最后他又回到了这个他最认为是家的街区，而且在奥克兰他仍然有老朋友。我们很多人，我和托弗里，他就睡在雷克萨斯里。对。他爸爸以前住在从这里数第五栋房子里，他们有一家名为“托弗货运”的公司。不错的卡车。天哪。
Of course, it makes perfect sense that most of Oakland's homeless population would be from Oakland. If you have even the most cursory awareness of what's happened to the housing market here in the last decade. Let's take the building I live in, where Michael used to live as an example. It's a 2,200 square foot duplex in North Oakland. In 2009, the assessment records showed it was worth $105,000. Last year, it was assessed at a million dollars, and would probably sell for quite a bit more than that. In the last five years, especially thousands of people like me
当然，奥克兰的大多数无家可归人口来自奥克兰，这完全合情合理。如果你对过去十年这里房地产市场发生的事情哪怕有最粗略的了解的话。让我们以我住的这栋楼为例，迈克尔以前就住在那里。这是一栋位于北奥克兰的 2,200 平方英尺的双户住宅。2009 年的评估记录显示它价值 105,000 美元。去年，它的估价是一百万美元，而且实际售价可能会比这高得多。在过去五年里，尤其是
have moved to the Bay Area for jobs, and the cost of rent in places like Oakland and Berkeley has skyrocketed. Low income African-American residents in the area have been the hardest hit by all of this. As new people have arrived, thousands of black people have moved away, and thousands have become homeless. My own neighborhood reflects this. My goal and I reflect this. But far beyond my block, you can see the effects of these economic and demographic shifts. Almost as if a tidal wave of wealth has washed the poor people of the Bay Area out of their houses and into the streets. I like a lot of people. I probably looked past all of this for a while.
成千上万像我这样的人为了工作搬到了湾区，奥克兰和伯克利等地的房租一路飙升。该地区低收入的非裔美国居民受到的冲击最为严重。随着新居民的涌入，成千上万的黑人搬走了，成千上万的人无家可归。我自己的社区反映了这一点。我和我的目标也反映了这一点。但远远超出了我的街区，你就能看到这些经济和 demographic 转变的影响。就好像一股财富的浪潮把湾区的穷人从他们的房子里冲刷到了街头。像许多人一样，我可能有一段时间对这一切视而不见。
But eventually just the sheer scale of it in my city became so startling that I started wanting to understand it and report on it. I didn't know what the story I wanted to tell was for a while. And it took me a bit to figure it out because there's this whole huge world you have to try to understand first. And to start this series I want to take you on a little tour of this world so that you can get a sense of it. The most visible way that homeless people live in the Bay Area is the tent encampment. Most of these encampments are easily seen from the road.
但最终，它在我这座城市展现出的纯粹规模变得如此惊人，以至于我开始想要去理解它并进行报道。有一段时间我不知道自己想讲述一个什么样的故事。我花了一点时间才弄清楚，因为首先你必须试着去理解一个巨大无比的世界。为了开启这个系列，我想带大家对这个世界进行一次简短的游览，让你们对它有一个直观的感受。湾区无家可归者最显眼的生活方式就是帐篷营地。这些营地大多从马路上就能一眼望见。
In fact, they're practically in the road. Tents and tarps and belongings spilling off of sidewalks and industries. But the encampment where Elizabeth Easton lives, in a tiny little house made out of plywood and two by fours. It was sort of hidden away down a dirt path next to some railroad tracks. Elizabeth told me she's always liked the idea of living in a tiny house. That's all I used to watch. Tiny house. On TV, yes, more than one.
事实上，它们几乎就搭在马路上。帐篷、防水布和各种物品从人行道和工业区溢出来。但伊丽莎白·伊斯顿居住的营地则不同，她住在用胶合板和二乘四木方搭成的小房子里。它有点隐蔽在一小条靠近铁轨的土路尽头。伊丽莎白告诉我，她一直都很喜欢住在小房子里的想法。那是我以前常看的节目。小房子。电视上的，对，不止一个。
Tiny house living, tiny house nation. She'd like to have a tiny house on some land that she's actually allowed to live on. But that's not what she has right now. Are you going to show me? Elizabeth's house is dark and windowless. There's a futon that takes up most of the space and then piles of tools and clothes. And then what's in that room? That's why I have my little toilet over there. Elizabeth's bathroom is maybe two and a half square feet with a dirt floor and one of those medical looking toilet chairs with a bucket underneath. Every few days she empties the bucket and burns the waste.
小房子生活，小房子国家。她希望能在某块她真正被允许居住的土地上拥有一座小房子。但这不是她现在拥有的。你要给我看看吗？伊丽莎白的房子黑洞洞的，没有窗户。里面有一张占据了大部分空间的折叠床，然后堆满了工具和衣服。那那个房间里是什么？那就是我放我的小马桶的地方。伊丽莎白的小浴室大概有两英尺半见方，泥土地面，放着一把那种医疗外观的马桶椅，下面放着一个桶。每隔几天，她就会倒掉桶里的东西并把排泄物烧掉。
She also has a small front yard with a fence made out of pallets, where her two dogs can lounge in the sun. It's a far cry from the places you see on Tiny House Nation, but it's still home. I know one thing, I'm not homeless. I put it that way. You know, it can say what they want to say, but I'm not homeless. I put it that way. It can say what they want to say, but I'm not homeless. I have a home. Elizabeth preferred to think of herself, not as homeless, but as home-steading. Home-steading is what she felt like she had done.
她还有一个由托盘搭成栅栏的小前院，她的两只狗可以在那里晒太阳。这和你在《小房子国家》里看到的那些地方相去甚远，但它依然是家。我知道一件事，我不是无家可归者。我是这么认为的。你知道，他们想怎么说就怎么说，但我不是无家可归者。我是这么认为的。他们想怎么说就怎么说，但我不是无家可归者。我有一个家。伊丽莎白更愿意认为自己不是无家可归，而是在“宅基地开荒”。宅基地开荒是她觉得自己一直在做的事。
Found a little piece of land and claimed it as her own. Built her own tiny house. But in her most powerless moments, she would talk about herself as homeless. Homesteading was a good day. Homeless was the day the police came and told her she couldn't be where she was anymore. Which had happened before and would happen again.
找到一小块土地并宣称它是自己的。建造自己的小房子。但在她最无力的时刻，她也会称自己为无家可归。宅基地开荒是美好的一天。无家可归则是警察来告诉她，她不能再待在这里的那一天。这种事以前发生过，以后还会发生。
The puzzle's parallel chain food. Of course, not everyone lives in an encampment. There are lots of people living in more hidden ways. A few miles from Elizabeth in what people sometimes call deep east Oakland. I'm at Reggie. See what I'm calling that? Come on. That's loud.
拼图的平行链条。当然，并不是每个人都住在营地里。有很多人以更隐蔽的方式生活。离伊丽莎白几英里远的一个人们有时称之为“东奥克兰深处”的地方。我遇到了雷吉。看看我怎么叫这个的？来吧。声音真大。
He sometimes sleeps in a broken-down minivan that's parked behind a house with a pit bull on a chain. But he can only sleep in the van when he can scrounge up 10 bucks. That's how much he has to pay to the owner of the van per night. He gets the money by panhandling. Could you just say where we are for the recording? Oh, that's the McDonald's. Everyone who lives in Oakland has been asked for money at some point by a panhandler. And there's long been an idea that giving cash to people on the street is the wrong way to support them. But I will say after my two years in the field, I basically think that's garbage.
他有时睡在一辆破旧的面包车里，车停在一栋养着一条拴着铁链的比特犬的房子后面。但他只有在能凑够 10 美元时才能睡在车里。那是他每晚必须支付给面包车车主的费用。他的钱是通过乞讨得来的。你能为了录音说一下我们现在在哪儿吗？哦，那是麦当劳。每个住在奥克兰的人都曾在某个时刻被乞讨者要过钱。长期以来有一种观点认为，给街头的人现金是支持他们的错误方式。但我可以说，在我实地调查两年之后，我基本上认为那是无稽之谈。
Some people buy drugs, sure. But even the ones who do are also buying food or water or like Reggie renting themselves a place to sleep at night. Like anyone else, they have a budget. Reggie has strong feelings about the do's and don'ts of asking people for money, which he was kind enough to guide me through. You shouldn't stand. His first piece of advice, don't stand between the window where the people pay and the window where they get their food. This is bad etiquette.
有些人买毒品，当然。但即使是那些买毒品的人，同时也买食物或水，或者像雷吉一样，租个地方过夜。和其他人一样，他们也有预算。雷吉对向人们要钱的“该做”和“不该做”有着强烈的看法，他非常友好地带我了解了这些。你不应该站着。他的第一个建议，不要站在人们付钱的那个窗户和他们取食物的那个窗户之间。这是不礼貌的。
This is hell of ghetto. This is ghetto. Oh, oh. Oh, that's it. But, okay. From this spot, you can see what changed people get before they even have a chance to put it back in their wallet. That ain't cool, you know, that is not cool. I think that's... That's like to aggressions, that's a great thing.
这太他妈贫民窟了。这太贫民窟了。哦，哦。哦，就是这样。但是，好吧。从这个地方，你可以看到人们在甚至还没机会把钱放回钱包之前就变了脸色。这可不酷，你知道，这绝对不酷。我觉得那……那是双重侵犯，这太糟糕了。
Also, don't bother people with kids, at least not in this part of Oakland, where everybody, even people with houses are struggling. You're taking away from the kids, well, you know, I don't like to do that, you know. And finally, don't be too hurt when people say no. That's when Reggie had to learn over time. You know, I'm just glad it don't hurt like I used to. It's hard not to get hurt when the stakes are this high. If Reggie can't panhandle the ten bucks for the minivan, he won't have anywhere to sleep tonight, and he'll end up just wandering the streets.
还有，不要打扰带孩子的，至少在奥克兰这部分不要，在这里每个人，甚至是有房子的人都在挣扎。你在剥夺孩子们的福利，嗯，你知道的，我不想那样做，你知道。最后，当人们拒绝时，不要太受伤。那是雷吉随着时间推移不得不学会的。你知道的，我只是很高兴它不像以前那样令人心痛了。当赌注这么高时，很难不感到受伤。如果雷吉无法乞讨到这十块钱来租面包车，他今晚就无处可睡，最后只能在街头流浪。
Reggie told me he wanted to find his stable place to live with his high school-aged daughter, who is also homeless and stays with a friend. But most of the time, he's so busy trying to survive that you just can't try to path out of this life. It's hard to get out of your home. You don't know what your life's gonna be the next two hours. You know, it just like swallows you up. And do you feel like there's a way for you to break
雷吉告诉我，他想和上高中的女儿找个稳定的地方住，女儿也无家可归，借住在朋友家。但大多数时候，他太忙于求生，以至于你根本无暇去规划摆脱这种生活的人生道路。很难摆脱你的家。你甚至不知道接下来的两个小时你的生活会变成什么样。你知道，它就像把你吞噬了一样。你觉得有办法打破
above that cycle? I can even answer that right now. Not all I know, I'm just, as my baby said, to break above that cycle. I can even answer that right now. All I know, I'm just, as my baby said, day by day dead. Day by day was how everyone I met outside lived. It's hard to make plans for the future and carry through with them while homeless.
那个循环吗？我甚至无法现在回答这个问题。我所知道的一切，就像我的宝贝女儿说的，打破那个循环。我甚至无法现在回答这个问题。我所知道的一切，就像我的宝贝女儿说的，过一天算一天。过一天算一天，这就是我在外面遇到的所有人的生活方式。无家可归的时候，很难对未来做出规划并将其付诸实施。
There's always some new crisis to deal with. Maybe your phone gets stolen or you lose your ID or you have to pick up all your things and move as fast as you can because someone doesn't want you where you are. So if you turn your car all the way off, it just starts honking. Yeah, look.
总是有各种新的危机需要应对。也许你的手机被偷了，或者你的身份证丢了，或者你不得不收拾好所有的东西，以最快的速度搬家，因为有人不希望你待在原来的地方。所以如果你把车完全熄火，它就会一直按喇叭。对，你看。
Yeah. Talia Garcia and her husband and six kids often end up sleeping in the car when they can't find a friend or relative to crash with. Today she's parked in front of her kids elementary school and her beat up old Ford Explorer. And her crisis right now is that when she turns her car off it lets out an unending honk which is mortifying. There's always something happening to me. Yeah. Yeah.
对。塔莉娅·加西亚和她的丈夫以及六个孩子，在找不到朋友或亲戚家借宿时，经常最后只能睡在车里。今天她把车停在她孩子的小学前面，开着她那辆破旧的老福特探险者。她眼下的危机是，当她把车熄火时，车子会发出没完没了的喇叭声，这太丢脸了。总是有各种事情发生在我身上。对。对。
I'm just like, OK. I don't even know what to think anymore. Talia had just had a little bit of good news, though. She found a woman who was willing to run a room to her and her husband and their kids. It was just one room for all eight of them, and it was only for a few months. Still, it was something. She wasn't sure what she would do after the three months was over,
我只是觉得，好吧。我甚至不知道该想什么了。不过，塔莉娅刚刚听到了一点好消息。她找到了一位愿意把一个房间租给她、她丈夫和孩子们的人。八个人挤在一个房间里，而且只能租几个月。尽管如此，总算有点着落了。她不确定三个月后该怎么办，
but she couldn't think too much about it at the moment. Because now there was a new crisis. Her car battery was dead. Like Michael, Elizabeth, and Reggie, and everyone I got to know over the last two years, Talia wanted permanent stable housing. She just couldn't figure out how to get it. For a lot of homeless people, the high cost of rent, coupled with the other barriers like deposit and good credit, rule out being able to get housing on their own without some kind of subsidy. There's Section 8 now officially called housing
但眼下她无暇多想。因为现在又有了新的危机。她的汽车电瓶没电了。就像迈克尔、伊丽莎白、雷吉以及我在过去两年里认识的每个人一样，塔莉娅想要永久、稳定的住房。她只是不知道该如何得到它。对许多无家可归者来说，高昂的房租，再加上押金和良好信用等其他门槛，使得他们在没有某种补助的情况下，根本无法靠自己的力量获得住房。现在有第八条（Section 8），官方现在称为住房
choice, which is a voucher program for low-income folks, but the wait lists are all currently closed in the Bay Area. Besides Section 8, there's the occasional low-income housing development that opens up, but the last one I heard about in Oakland had 28 units, and they got 4,000 applications. And so what's left in terms of help? Basically, what's left is the homeless service system. It might surprise some of you to know that we even have a system in place to help homeless people get inside, but we do. And after exploring a lot of different corners
选择券（Housing Choice），这是一个针对低收入人群的代金券项目，但在湾区，所有的等待名单目前都已关闭。除了第八条，偶尔会有低收入住房开发项目开放，但我听说奥克兰最近的一个项目有 28 套公寓，却收到了 4,000 份申请。那么在援助方面还剩下什么呢？基本上，剩下的就是无家可归者服务系统。你们中的有些人可能会惊讶地发现，我们甚至还有一个现成的系统来帮助无家可归者住进室内，但我们确实有。在探索了无家可归世界的许多不同角落，
of the world of homelessness, and talking to hundreds of people, this system is what I decided this series should be about. Because this is it, like this is the system we have right now to solve homelessness, which is a huge issue in this country. We already have hundreds of thousands of people dealing with homelessness nationwide, and we may soon see a dramatic increase due to COVID-related job losses and evictions. And so how this system works is a question with huge stakes.
并与数百人交谈之后，我决定将这个系统作为本系列节目的主题。因为这就是全部，这就是我们目前用来解决无家可归问题的系统，这是一个在这个国家极其严重的问题。全国范围内已经有数十万人面临无家可归的困境，由于新冠疫情导致的工作岗位流失和驱逐潮，我们可能很快会看到这一数字急剧增加。因此，这个系统是如何运作的，是一个事关重大的问题。
And yet it's the part of this world that I honestly had to work the hardest to understand. It's confusing and opaque. Some might say Kafka-esque and they wouldn't be wrong. Everyone I met had interacted with this system. Some like Reggie had given up on it. This is designed to keep a mo-damn man. This is not designed for nobody to come up. These programs are not designed to really come up.
然而，老实说，这也是我为了理解它而付出最大努力的部分。它令人困惑且不够透明。有些人可能会说它带有卡夫卡式的色彩，而且他们说得没错。我遇到的每个人都与这个系统打过交道。有些人像雷吉一样，已经对它彻底死心了。这个系统旨在把穷人死死压在底下。这不是为了让任何人能翻身而设计的。这些程序根本不是为了让人真正翻身而设计的。
Other people like Talia were still waiting to get something from it. What does it take to be priority for them? I don't understand it. What does it take to be priority for them? I don't understand it. Talia isn't alone. A lot of people don't understand what it takes to be a priority in this system. But I can finally say that I do. It's a system that prioritizes resources according to need. But how do you decide whether one person needs housing more than another? And who actually gets help when there are so many people who need it? That's what we're going to explore over the next few weeks. Stay tuned. Thank you. you you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
其他人，比如塔莉娅，还在苦等它能带来点什么。要达到什么标准才能成为他们的优先对象？我不明白。要达到什么标准才能成为他们的优先对象？我不明白。塔莉娅并不孤单。很多人都不明白在这个系统中成为优先对象需要具备什么条件。但我终于可以说我懂了。这是一个根据需求来优先分配资源的系统。但是，你怎么能决定一个人比另一个人更需要住房呢？在有这么多人需要帮助的时候，究竟是谁得到了帮助呢？这就是我们将在接下来的几周里探讨的内容。请继续收听。谢谢。本集尚无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。